ماثيو ماذا قال الرئيس زيلينسكي ،
نعم ، أعني حقًا
لحظة حرجة لأننا الآن على
شفا ما يعتقد الكثير من الناس أنه سيكون
جهدًا روسيًا ضخمًا لقصف
عاصمة أوكرانيا هنا في كييف
ومحاولة حقيقية
منسقة للسيطرة على
لقد ظهر الرئيس الأوكراني فلاديمير زيلينسكي كما تعلمون
الزعيم الحقيقي في زمن الحرب لهذا البلد
وكان من الصعب جدًا الوصول
إليه لأنك تعلم أنه من الواضح
أنه في مكان سري في وسط
كييف ويسمح لي أن أقول ذلك  لكن كان علينا
أن نلتقي بقوات أوكرانية مدججة بالسلاح
في مكان معين ، ثم أخذنا
بسيارتهم إلى الطابق السفلي من
مبنى في مكان ما في وسط المدينة ،
وكان علينا السير عبر هذه
الممرات المظلمة للغاية التي تصطف عليها جميعًا
بأكياس الرمل مع قوات الأمن في
كل مكان حتى  كنا في
أعماق أحشاء هذا المبنى الضخم في
وسط كييف حيث في أحد
الأماكن التي قيل لنا فيها
الرئيس فلاديمير زيلينسكي  أوكرانيا أم
تعلمون نوعًا من المعسكرات يختبئ بها كما
تعلمون القوات الروسية تقصف
البلاد وطبعًا تقصف العاصمة أيضًا
من حيث المقابلة التي
أجريت بشكل رئيسي أه باللغة الأوكرانية كانت
بعض الأسئلة التي أجابنا عليها
أه فيها  اللغة الإنجليزية تحدثنا عن مجموعة من
القضايا وهنا واحدة من
القضايا التي تحدثنا عنها تحدثنا
عن أه المفاوضات التي
بدأت قبل أيام بين
روسيا وأوكرانيا حول كيفية
وضع حد لهذا الصراع ووضع حد
لهذا العنف.  استمع إلى
إرسال وفدك للقاء
الروس لإجراء محادثات ،
ففعل أي شيء جوهري خرج من
ذلك ، فهل هناك أي أمل
لأن العالم يشاهد الدبلوماسية قرروا
أه يشرعوا في الحديث عن هذا
الوضع وأريده أنا أريده حقًا وأنا
طلبت منهم ذلك ، لذا عليك أن تتحدث أولاً وقبل
كل شيء ، يجب على الجميع
التوقف عن القتال والذهاب إلى هذه
النقطة
من حيث بدأ ، نعم ، لقد بدأت خمسة
ستة اليوم ستة أيام وستة أيام  اذهب نعم أعتقد أن
هناك أشياء أساسية يمكنك القيام
بها وهذه لحظة مهمة للغاية إذا
كنت ستفعل ذلك وإذا كان هذا الجانب
جاهزًا فهذا يعني أنهم مستعدون للقطعة
إذا لم يكونوا مستعدين فهذا يعني أنك "
أنت تعلم فقط
هل تعتقد أنك تضيع وقتك أم
تعتقد أنهم مستعدون ،
سنرى
كل شيء على ما يرام يمكننا أن نرى
الرئيس زيلينسكي هناك
يبدو شاحبًا جدًا ويبدو أنك تعلم أنه متعب
عيناه حمراء  إنه غير حليق
ومن الواضح أنه تحت ضغط كبير
، قرر البقاء في وسط
العاصمة الأوكرانية على الرغم من أنه
قال بنفسه إنه يعتقد أنه
الهدف الأول للقوات الروسية
وأن عائلته هي الهدف الثاني
كما قال.  هذا قبل عدة أيام ،
ولكن انظر
، سُئل عما إذا كنت تعرف
كيف كان يتعامل معه وما إذا كنت
تعرف أنه شاهد عائلته على سبيل المثال
أيضًا وقال ، انظر ، لم
أرهم كما تعلمون لعدة أيام على ما أعتقد
لمدة ثلاثة أيام لم يرهم و
s  أنت تعرف أن هذا رجل
كان في الأصل ممثلًا كوميديًا ، فقد
أصبح رئيسًا له دور كبير في حد ذاته ،
والآن برز على أنه نوع مهم حقًا
تعرفه هو
شخصية محورية في الدفاع عن أوكرانيا كما
تعلم ولكنك تعلم  ها هو يقود
البلاد من هذا المخبأ حيث
تستعد القوات الروسية على
مشارف المدينة لضرب العاصمة الأوكرانية.